Let's get started sooner rather than later I get it
Shuichi is impatient
[music] I'm
drinking and watching
what's going on because I'm going to be in week 1 from now on
11 Why am I transforming and what about that
coin?  I
said I'd like to know if it's something to do with it,
but if I look into it, it
means that there's still a chance I'll encounter a monster like that woman
So when we get together now,
what?  I need to know properly if I can do it
Shuichi says that if he understands, he will transform into a butterfly as soon as possible,
but he says he does, but
why does he need to take off his clothes
?  It
might be nice to stay warm in winter, but it's
summer, and even
my underwear is soaked with sweat.  It's
okay if you pick up someone who comes over.  It's
easy to wash, and I'd rather be in a school swimsuit
than naked You're a maniac, aren't you
?
Ha
ha,
yeah, yeah,
this feeling is the
same as before
I can
clearly feel that Claire is inside of me I can
feel the tension of the first week It's
like my body in spring
Strangely, I seem to be able to move that I can't normally do What about
Shuichi
?  I can
move it with I'll try Yeah, yeah, what's going on?  So
I'm on my left hand and
Shuichi's on my right hand.